tout le monde l'aimait tout le monde le
respectait tout le monde l'admirait
c'est rare que quelqu'un fasse autant
l'unanimité mais il fait l'unanimité que
ce soit on va lui rendre hommage c'est
que le Québec est en deuil aujourd'hui
on pleure on a des plus grands comédiens
de notre histoire tant au cinéma à la
télé côté théâtre puis surtout un des
préférés des Québécois plusieurs disent
aujourd'hui il y a un peu de nous en
Michel Côté mais il est décédé trop
jeune à 72 ans et s'est battu là avec
une grande résilience quand une maladie
maladie de la moelle osseuse c'est toute
la dernière année l'amenait ce combat et
pendant 50 ans il faut dire qu'il a
marqué notre
paysage culturel en fait notre évolution
culturel est incrustée dans nos vies et
que ce soit vraiment théâtre au cinéma
puis à la télé ben c'est le personnage
sont mémorables ils nous ont fait rire
ça c'est certain campe de rire ça c'est
sûr mais ils ont aussi beaucoup pleuré
et puis plusieurs ont pleuré ce matin en
apprenant cette nouvelle puis en fait on
commence cette heure en soulignant qu'il
a été au centre des deux plus grands
succès culturel à la télé au théâtre de
l'histoire du Québec évidemment la
légendaire pièce de théâtre Brou et la
série culte la petite vie on écoute un
court extrait de chacune de ces
réalisations
[Musique]
surtout pour un pompier
à sortir leur animal féminin yeah
[Applaudissements]
c'est super super
et ce ne sont que quelques unes de ces
très grandes performances alors on va
lui rendre hommage avec nos invités au
cours de cette prochaine heure et on
commence avec Claude Meunier coauteur de
Brou bonsoir Claude Meunier
vous avez été commis bien ses côtés vous
êtes auteur de la petite vie alors merci
d'être avec nous Claude et en studio
avec moi Pierre Séguin réalisateur de la
petite vie et grand admirateur de Michel
Côté bonsoir pierre Seguin et Michel
Coulomb chroniqueur cinéma mais
historien du cinéma qui a suivi dès le
début de la carrière de Michel coton
parler de quelqu'un qu'on aime ça doit
être riche vous sent tout le temps oui
c'est un bonheur parce que il nous a
offert beaucoup pour essayer de lui
rendre hommage mon Dieu
je commence avec vous en disant quand
même vous êtes un pivot aussi dans la
vie de Michel Côté sa carrière puisque
vous êtes coteur des deux grandes
réussites
de Michel Côté sur la scène culturelle
parlez-moi de l'homme que vous avez aimé
et pour qui vous avez écrit
c'est un peu l’œuf ou la poule avec
Michel parce que une unité de Michel de
Marc Messier aussi je sais pas si
j'aurai autant de succès dans l'écriture
puis dans le avant d'un comédien comme
Michel coté quand tu écris c'est
formidable c'est assez exceptionnel
à mon Dieu parler de Michel
c'est difficile d'en parler d'une façon
succincte parce que c'est je dirais que
c'est quelqu'un d'unique quelqu'un de
très marquant c'est quelqu'un
qui ressemble pas à personne ni dans son
talent ni dans son jeu
comment dire si tu as quelqu'un de Total
complètement à 100% impliqué dans ces
rôles qui jouait d'une manière unique il
jouait jusqu'au bout des ongles il y
avait un jeu tellement
même dans des trucs très drôles il y
avait un jeu très raffiné très très
élaboré ça paraît pas peut-être tout le
temps mais il était toujours à la
recherche de la perfection gestuelle
[Musique]
mentale de ces personnages il y avait
une psyché incroyable puis je disais ça
aujourd'hui à travers tous ces rôles on
retrouvait quand même une espèce de sens
de Michel Côté qui était il était
flamboyant sans vouloir l'être il était
unique et même force qui se dégageait de
Michel un aura il était excessivement
charismatique et il y avait un talent
naturel un jeu naturel assez peu comme
c'est un acteur hors de l'ordinaire j'ai
eu la chance qui joue quel pas mal de
mes textes un moment donné puis il était
exceptionnels qui vont faire l'histoire
pour les textes qu'ils étaient et pour
le succès qu'ils ont connu parce qu'ils
ont fait vibrer la scène culturelle
partout au Québec dans toutes les
régions encore la petite vie aujourd'hui
avec les reprises et rassembleurs Brou
pendant quand même 40 ans et plus Pierre
c'est gain vous avez réalisé la petite
vie à côté de lui est-ce que réalisateur
se fait humble devant un artiste de
grands talent comme on dirige à Michel
coté on le laisse on le regarde aller
plus
Michel pour moi c'est un c'est quelqu'un
qui était ma foi ami avec tout le monde
sur les plateaux il s'intéressait au
travail de chacun de chacune ils
connaissait souvent les noms les prénoms
de chacun des membres de l'équipe
c'est un gars sympathique un vrai bon
gars qu'on veut avoir comme ami là c'est
ça qui dégage aussi c'est sûr que tout
le monde dit ça de l'avoir comme ami il
me semble qu'on le connaît c'est ça
aussi il était sur le plateau exactement
comme sur comme on le connaît dans ces
dans ces grands rôles dans ces
sympathiques capables de tout champ est
capable d'être ça c'est quand même il
faut pas oublier que dans les premières
moutures de la petite vie il jouait
aussi
omerta le mardi le lundi on était en on
avec la petite vie et souvent Jean-Loup
était là puis le mardi sont commandant
dans l'excq dans dans omerto c'était
complètement l'opposé personne n'a
jamais dit oh mon Dieu tu as vu
Jean-Louis dans Martin il était capable
de Saint-Michel de de définir ces rôles
tellement de façon extraordinaire
magistrale que qui qui nous faisait
oublier ces autres
pour les compositions il faut le dire
parce que Jean-Loup c'est exagéré c'est
fantaisistes et on l'aime donc qu'est-ce
qui mettait lui là dedans tout était
dans les textes tout était parce que je
peux rendre hommage à Claude un peu
aussi en disant que Claude
écrit Claude écrit pour les pour tous
ces personnages de façon égale de façon
il donne des bonnes lignes à tout le
monde de Normandie mais Michel c'est les
prendre au bon puis les jouer avec la
comédie c'est pas facile c'est comme un
rythme
c'est très difficile écrire pour faire
rire n'est-ce pas et vous êtes d'accord
avec cette pierre nous dit
mais je dois dire que Michel avait une
facilité déconcertante à faire à jouer
de l'humour à jouer des personnages
drôles parce qu'il y avait un langage
corporel très drôle y était comment dire
il trouvait toujours une manière
d'aborder de façon totale vous êtes
tantôt mais il y avait il y avait un
charisme fou il y avait un rythme
incroyable Michel Côté et Marc mais
c'est parce que c'est une paire en même
temps
en jouet Brou pendant 40 ans et même un
peu plus que 40 ans et
toutes les fois que moi je l'ai revu
c'était toujours la main le même
standard il y avait une sorte de rigueur
et à la fin la dernière représentation
puis Michel il m'a dit trouves-tu encore
correct si je me rappelle de ça ce soir
alors chaque soir il s'en faisait avec
la qualité de l'interprétation il y a
toujours que ça soit toujours aussi bien
joué il était maniaque dans le jeu il
était vraiment
Brou va donner cousine
toute passée tout était un extrait de
Monsieur le côté en entrevue avec mon
collègue Louis-Philippe oui mais
c'est remarquable style nous dit on
l'écoute
j'ai de la compassion pour mes
personnages je les défends je les aime
même si c'est des bandits non parce que
il y a des types qui sont en prison puis
leur mère les hommes c'est-à-dire il y a
toujours un peu rien du tout gris rien
du tout blanc rien n'est tout noir c'est
à dire il y a toujours du bon dans un
mauvais et du mauvais dans un bon et moi
quand je joue un personnage je me dis je
vais être ce personnage là à 100%
ce qu'on appelle ça de l'intégrité de
l'authenticité Claude Meunier
oui tout à fait Michel avait un amour de
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un amour de ces
personnages il y avait un amour du
public aussi il jouait tout le temps
pour les gens ils jouaient il était très
soucieux de du public qui était il y
avait une espèce d'intégrité incroyable
puis il y avait un souci du détail
remarquable il y avait une intelligence
aussi Michel était un gars excessivement
de Jean-Loup voir en quelque sorte un
peu là pour la petite ville tout à fait
Michel était m'a demandé de Michel Le
apparemment
dit Michel aimerait ça venait faire un
tour à la petite vie un personnage à te
proposer et il m'est arrivé que une
proposition de Jean-Louis qui était pas
que j'ai modifié un petit peu mais c'est
Michel qui est arrivé avec l'idée et
puis moi je l'ai rendu un peu plus
sceptible j'ai mis des travailleurs et
tout ça mais les personnes les comédiens
apportent tellement aux personnages
aussi quelque chose mais il s'est jamais
complet et Michel il y avait apporté
beaucoup de beaucoup d'émotions comment
dire beaucoup de sensibilités
vous l'aviez dirigé en 89 oui il fallait
lui laisser la liberté au-delà du texte
donc de l'incarner le personnage mais
d'y mettre de sa propre inspiration
c'est ça aussi de la composition Michel
mais ça c'est clair pour faire de la
composition faut partir de soi quand
même c'est ça et pour vous là dessus
c'est sûr que Michel c'est on a juste à
voir ces personnages dans Crazy dans
tout le cinéma ou ce qui était c'est un
immense interprète comme un
transformiste presque parce que avec les
prothèses avec ce genre d'affaires c'est
ça qui
a ajouté quelque chose
j'allais dire comme dit Michel c'est
c'était un champion de la composition
vous pouvez composer d'une façon
exceptionnelle des personnages mais il y
arrivait toujours avec composition très
complète très articulée et très nuancé
malgré que c'est à dire des rôles des
fois
juste comique mais il y avait il y avait
beaucoup de structure puis de réflexion
je vous laisse aller maintenant Claude
Pierre et Michel vont rester avec nous
mais Claude on vous offre aussi nos
condoléances parce que c'est un
partenaire de vie une vie
professionnelle ça nous habite et si
j'ajoutais moi j’écoutais tout le monde
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un homme qui
a été très aimé mais quand on regarde
l'ensemble de ses réalisations on a
l'impression qu'il nous laisse en
héritage que de la beauté et que le goût
du bonheur
puis nous autres ses amis c'est quand
même je pense à Mac qui était très
proche de lui Marcel c'est un peu de
nous autres vraiment qui s'en va parce
que il était parti d'un move on était un
mouvement ou un style de jeu qui est
arrivé dans les années 80 ou de d'humour
c'est une partie de ça qui s'en va aussi
à la famille reçoit mais à vous aussi
merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI